"Supongamos que el 8% de todos los autos que se
producen en la planta A tiene cierto defecto,
y que 6% de todos los autos que se producen
en la planta B tiene ese defecto. Cada mes,
un gerente de control de calidad toma muestras
aleatorias independientes de 200 de los más de
3,000 autos producidos por cada planta. El gerente
evalúa la diferencia entre las proporciones de
autos con el defecto en cada muestra."
Entonces, él evalúa la diferencia en las
proporciones muestrales de cada mes. "Describe
la distribución de la proporción de la muestra
de la planta A menos la proporción de la muestra
de la planta B en términos de su media,
desviación estándar y forma." Así que hagamos esto
paso a paso. Primero pensemos en la media de la
diferencia de nuestras proporciones muestrales.
Pausa el video e intenta encontrar la respuesta.
Bueno, hemos visto esto en videos pasados,
que la media de la diferencia de dos variables
aleatorias equivale a la diferencia de las
medias. La manera de establecer esto es que,
si queremos encontrar la media de la proporción
muestral de la planta A menos la proporción
muestral de la planta B, esto será igual a la
media de la proporción muestral de la planta A
menos la media de la proporción muestral de la
planta B. Ahora, ¿a qué será igual esto? Bueno,
¿cuál es la media de la proporción muestral de la
planta A? Bueno, esto será igual a la proporción
poblacional real de la planta A; y nos la dan: nos
dicen que el 8% de todos los autos que se producen
en la planta A tiene cierto defecto, entonces,
esta será 8% o podemos escribir 0.08. Y a esto le
restaremos la media de la proporción muestral de
la planta B, y sabemos a qué equivale esta media:
la media de la proporción muestral será la
proporción poblacional, el parámetro de la
población que sabemos que, para la planta B, es
de 6% o 0.06. Y entonces esto es igual a una
media de diferencia de 0.02 o 2%: la media es una
diferencia del 2% en la tasa del defecto. Ahora,
pensemos en la desviación estándar, pero en lugar
de pensar en términos de la desviación estándar,
pensemos en el cuadrado de la desviación estándar
que es la varianza (σ); una vez calculada ésta podemos
regresar a la desviación estándar tomando la raíz
cuadrada. Bien, si buscamos la varianza de
la diferencia de las proporciones muestrales, es
decir, la proporción muestral de la planta A menos
la proporción muestral de la planta B -recordemos
que, si suponemos que las muestras de las plantas
son independientes, es decir, que el muestreo
de la planta A no afecta el muestreo de la
planta B y viceversa, entonces podemos sumar las
varianzas-, entonces esto será igual a la varianza
de la proporción muestral de la planta A más la
varianza de la proporción muestral de la planta B.
Y tal vez algunos de ustedes digan: "Espera, ¿no
queríamos tomar la diferencia de las proporciones
muestrales?, ¿por qué estamos sumando?" Pero
recuerda: la varianza es una medida de dispersión,
y ya sea que tomemos la diferencia de variables
aleatorias o tomemos la sumas de ellas, cuando
tengamos más variables tendremos más dispersión.
Entonces, independientemente de si esto es
negativo o positivo, esto será positivo. Entonces,
¿a qué será igual todo esto? Bueno, podemos buscar
cada uno de estos términos. ¿Cuál será la varianza
de la proporción de la muestra de la planta A?
Bueno, si cada vez que observamos uno de sus autos
lo observamos y lo regresamos a la población,
entonces, si muestreamos con reemplazo -lo que
significa que cada una de nuestras observaciones
es independiente de las otras-, entonces tenemos
una fórmula. Sabemos que esta varianza será la
proporción poblacional de la planta A, por 1 menos
la proporción poblacional de la planta A, dividido
entre el tamaño de la muestra de la planta A.
Ahora, en el ejemplo que estamos resolviendo
no estamos muestreando con reemplazo, en este caso
tomamos 200 autos al mismo tiempo y los evaluamos;
no tomamos sólo uno, lo reemplazamos y hacemos
esto doscientas veces. Pero también sabemos que
si la muestra es menor que el 10% de la población,
entonces esta es una aproximación muy buena,
incluso si el muestreo es sin reemplazo, y 200
es menor que el 10% de 3000. Así que esta es una
aproximación muy buena, y es la que usaremos en
el curso básico de estadística. De igual manera,
podemos establecer la misma consideración para la
varianza de la proporción muestral de la planta B,
ésta será igual a la proporción poblacional de la
planta B, por 1 menos la proporción poblacional
de la planta B, dividido entre el tamaño de la
muestra de la planta B. Y ya conocemos estos
datos: sabemos que la proporción poblacional de
la planta A es 8% o 0.08, 1 menos eso es 0.92,
el tamaño de la muestra es de 200 autos para
la planta A; y para la planta B sabemos que su
proporción poblacional es del 6% o 0.06, 1
menos eso es 0.94 y el tamaño de la muestra
de la planta B también es 200. Y tenemos que:
0.08 x 0.92 / 200 más, y abrimos paréntesis,
(0.06 x 0.94 / 200), cerramos el paréntesis, y nos
da este resultado: 0.00065, 0.00065. Ahora bien,
con este resultado podemos encontrar la desviación
estándar. La desviación estándar de la diferencia
entre nuestras proporciones muestrales será la
raíz cuadrada de este resultado, será la √0.00065,
y esto es aproximadamente igual a, calculamos la
raíz cuadrada y obtenemos 0.025, 0.025. Listo,
hemos encontrado la desviación estándar. Y,
por último, pero no por eso menos importante,
pensemos en la forma de la distribución. Tenemos
que recordar que mientras tengamos al menos 10
éxitos y 10 fracasos, la distribución de cada
proporción muestral será una normal. Así que
veamos, ¿cuántos éxitos esperamos, donde un éxito
será un auto defectuoso? Vamos a pensarlo: 8% de
la muestra de 200 serán 16, esperamos 16 autos
defectuosos y esperamos 200 - 16, que es mucho
más grande que 10, de no defectuosos. Entonces
ambas cantidades son mayores o iguales a 10. Y
si hacemos lo mismo para la planta B, tenemos la
misma situación: 6% de 200 es 12, mientras que los
que no son defectuosos son 200 - 12, que es mucho
mayor que 10, especialmente en este último caso,
pero en cada situación esperamos tener al
menos 10 éxitos y 10 fracasos. Por lo tanto,
podemos suponer que las distribuciones de cada
una de ellas van a ser normales. También sabemos
que la diferencia entre dos variables distribuidas
normalmente también es normal, siempre y cuando se
cumpla esa condición de frecuencias grandes que
acabamos de considerar. Entonces dibujemos cómo
se vería esta distribución. Podría verse algo como
esto, va a ser una distribución normal, en la que
tenemos la media justo aquí -que haremos en ese
mismo color, una media de 0.02-, y definitivamente
pueden tener valores negativos porque pueden
darse de manera aleatoria situaciones en las que
la proporción de la muestra de la planta B pueda
ser mayor que la proporción de la muestra de la
planta A, así que definitivamente puede tomar
valores negativos. Y si queremos mostrar dónde
está el 0 -tal vez el 0 esté justo aquí, por lo
que podremos dibujar un eje por aquí-, y luego,
ya sabemos cuál es la desviación estándar, es
aproximadamente 0.025; con eso podemos señalar
una desviación estándar por debajo de la media y
una desviación estándar por encima de la media, y
obviamente podríamos ir más allá de una desviación
estándar por encima o por debajo de esa media.